the city of cape town
is under attack by an unpredictable foe
and it has torn through a verdant strip
which occupies the heart of this
community
views of table mountain now obscured
by billowing clouds of smoke and its
slopes
are ablaze as the wind whips and fans
the fires
this natural calamity started in the
vegetation
above the city's university and it
quickly grew
now the lives and livelihoods of tens of
thousands are threatened we're moving
into the the felt
the grasslands which surround table
mountain and
there are pockets of flame shooting up
and a whole lot of smoke and just up
ahead
a small number of fire fighters with
hoses
trying to douse the flames it's a really
unpleasant place to be
there are 250 people fighting this fire
and they have been given one critical
objective
stop the blaze from moving down the
mountain and into the city itself
which way is the fire spreading at the
moment it's going
uh in our easterly direction so it's
going around the mountain right there
okay it's already uh jumped the road and
it's already gone to the houses on the
other side
yeah okay okay oh this is this is a
difficult situation isn't it very
difficult situation because the wind can
change anytime
strong gusts of wind drove the fire in
the direction of a neighborhood
called ferreira hook and we watched one
man douse his home
with the garden hose are these houses in
danger
most residents had evacuated but alet
loebscher
had returned to survey the scene and she
took us to see her garden
this morning very early they evacuated
everybody so we went
out and we came back because it actually
looked like it was coming down
it looked like it was actually it was
under control and then suddenly the wind
just turned
now it's we're back to square one
firefighters have formed a
final line of defense in areas like
ferrada hook
and they are going to have to hold this
line for several days to come
john sparks sky news in cape town